luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show i'm really excited to jump straight into
this one because this is gonna be um a fun topic
put it this way i've been trying to get this guy
on for quite a few maybe like over a year now i
think it's been so i'm very excited but before
we jump in um it is powered by icon plus capital
so quick news announcement for you so the new d5
platform running on icon is now live um on balance
you can stick icx's collateral to borrow usd
interest free and also they provide around seven
percent um daily interest on yield farming rewards
now this is also um sponsored by block five so
quick shout out to them you can get up to eight
point six percent interest on your usdc um so i'll
leave a link for you somewhere and everywhere now
before i bring on my guest um if you are watching
on youtube please don't forget to hit subscribe
hit the like button so you never miss any of these
brilliant guests so today joining me like i said
is someone i have been trying to get on for um
quite some time who's a bitcoin advocate investor
financial consultant and the founder
and ceo of the financial consulting firm
atlantic financial it is bruce benton bruce
how are you great how are you great to see you
yeah it's really good to see you as i
was saying i think i've been trying to
chat to you have a good podcast have a good
chat for maybe over a year now yeah that doesn't
surprise me i i used to do these once in a while
and i haven't done a lot for for quite some time
i've done some clubhouses but i haven't appeared
on any i don't know this may be one of the first
in a while maybe i've done a few in the last year
if that so i don't do too many of them oh well i
feel honored but you mentioned clubhouse which is
pretty interesting what are your thoughts on that
right now because i think i heard i think i read
some news the other day that the downloads of that
is actually going down yeah they kind of have to
because they had so many you know soon everybody
will have it but i think it's great i wish i would
have sent a check to them and tried to invest my i
had an idea by the time i heard about it everybody
i mean i was pretty early but but but the other
i was using number about 4 800 but i think like
4 000 of the other ones were all vcs so it wasn't
like it was a secret you know so it would have
been easy for them to to raise money um but i
thought about just sending you know i've heard of
people investors sending a check and just saying
hey let me in on your next round like no terms no
nothing i i thought about taking a risk and doing
that it might have been early enough i don't know
if they would have but i sure wish i would have
invested i i knew for sure this one was going to
be a big hit and it has been it's a great it's a
great format so that's cool you don't think it's
sort of like hit its peak and it's potentially
coming down from there uh probably not its peak
i think it it hit its initial like um adoption
curve kind of you know it's it that that you can
only be hot and new once you know but it still
has a ways to go i don't even know if they have
android yet but once they do that they should have
uh quite a bit um you know quite quite a bit more
users and and i think there will be more people
that have large followings that have large rooms
and some podcasts that might migrate there and
other things so it's still early i i would imagine
it's probably going to be a pretty cool looking
platform in a few years but there may be others
the other thing is it's easy for somebody else
to come and replace it yeah yeah that's the thing
with social media these days it's just a matter of
everybody just copying what everybody's doing
i mean even going back a few years snapchat did
the stories instagram you know twitter with the
spaces it's just one thing after the other but um
i want to go back a little bit learn a bit more
about you and how you initially got into the
space before we talk about everything um that i've
been dying to speak to about sure yeah i started
in the investment business when i was a little
kid basically my mom was a stock broker and uh
in the and i kind of grew up in the brokerage firm
floor i would come there every day every day after
school not just some days but every day i'd come
there and i'd just play on the floor and listen to
the brokers talking and that this was a different
time you know that the 80s especially like uh
it was more like the crypto space it was exciting
there was a lot of money it was you know there's
brokers yelling there's drama people arguing with
each other you know they even in those days when
i was a little kid they were still like verbally
doing orders you know so people would be yelling
across the floor you buy 300 shares well you
know and i thought that was really cool and we
had the crazy kind of cool stories like we have in
crypto my mom came home one day and told me about
somebody in her office who got arrested um and the
sec came the sec came with the police and like and
the fbi and they arrested somebody yeah so it's
just crazy uh it was a crazy industry and so
i was interested in that very young and by
and when i was 14 i got like a real job there
as an assistant uh back when you were allowed to
do that you were even allowed to call customers
really yeah yeah i mean you know you have to
be licensed uh to do most of the things uh to
they just they made it more strict about what you
had to be you used to be able to kind of call and
sort of pre-qualify people cold call for a broker
um but now you need to be licensed to do that but
so i started very early and i did that um you
know when i when i was a little kid all the
way through my teens and then when i got out
of the navy i went and got a full-time job at
dean witter which was as a stockbroker
financial advisor so i did that for for
20 something years or you know about around
20 years and and i focused on emerging markets
and emerging technologies and that went well you
know we we were early on the internet and we did
well with the dot-com boom and uh and bust we
called the bust actually and then uh so i was
familiar with this kind of thing so so crypto was
a natural uh thing for me i was interested in free
markets uh economics globalization technology sort
of checked all those boxes for me so i got into
crypto about eight years ago and sort of started
working full-time there wasn't really like paid
work or companies you know there was only i think
two or three companies that had venture funding
and there was probably only half a dozen jobs that
were paid you know there was like gavin andreessen
and i i became executive director of the bitcoin
foundation so we would pay uh or that organization
used to pay those kind of salaries um and so i've
been in it ever since and i've been interested in
the things that converge those two areas that i
came from securities and and crypto and bitcoin
uh and the rest is history i guess yeah i think
it's fascinating because you've been able to
see such a change in that financial space like you
were saying back when you were 14 they were making
you know actual calls and and all these things
and i think that wild west is sort of what we're
seeing now and you can make those synergies in
in some ways but you've been really vocal when
it comes to d5 i remember you you did that video
and it was like the drawing and the fire and
that was fun um but i can't i do want to talk a
little bit about d5 and all the different things
that are being built right now um so firstly would
you regard yourself at all as a bitcoin maximalist
i like the term jameson lope it was the first
one i heard say it which is bitcoin monetary
maximalist so i believe that bitcoin is the best
money and store of value and i think bitcoin is
the best doing for the the thing that it's
trying to do but uh unlike some people who
are who are just sort of the next sentence
they would say is everything else is junk i
don't think everything else is junk i'm optimistic
particularly about security securities have value
they just do whether you like it or not you
know it doesn't being a token doesn't erase
the value so i think it's a very neanderthal
uh idea to say like all tokens are bad and they
always will be other than bitcoin that's just
uh not nuanced not that smart neanderthal view
uh but you know it comes it's rooted in something
that's kind of true which is that almost all of
these things are junk uh so so you you know i
take the the technology i'm excited about the
ideas i'm excited about but they're you know i'm
definitely one of the first to say that there's
a lot of just junky projects you know projects
that don't make sense and i don't i don't like
the word i think the word scam is overused more
much more common than scams and some are scams
much more common that scams are just you know real
naive uh people or you know naive plans or just um
naive to the point of being negligent almost
where people just just have such a bad idea that
it almost has the same function as a scam and and
they just very naive but overall i'm kind of uh
you know more open-minded than than most people
who might refer to themselves as pure bitcoin
maximalist yeah i appreciate that i think nuances
is really important and we're seeing you know the
building of web 3 and everything that you saw you
know since the beginning of the internet um i just
think it's so um i do think it's closed-minded
to not be open to what could come next
so i kind of want your opinion in terms of deep
buy what kind of value do you think it brings
and where do you see where do you see that value
um in comparison to bitcoin so i guess you would
look at bitcoin as that store of value and defy
and everything that's been built on ethereum where
do you see that playing out yeah so d5 is pretty
broad uh term overall and it encompasses a lot
so kind of defining it is sometimes hard when
it first came out it was just sort of like
you know it sounds like everything else you know
but but if you get into what it really should
mean which is the two two words decentralized and
finance that's pretty easy so you want to look at
something that's truly decentralized and then with
that you ask well why do you need it decentralized
some things it doesn't make sense to decentralize
early in the bitcoin era people were talking about
dows and stuff just sort of decentralizing
for the sake of decentralizing it doesn't
always make sense and in some cases like a
company it can actually be a negative you
do sort of want to have centralization sometimes
the best companies have that you know elon musk or
jack welsh or whoever's driving it um and then
the other part is is finance and that's pretty
broad also that includes lending lending's a huge
part of finance it includes securities which is
what i'm most interested in so i think that it's
very early stage i think there's it's kind of like
um when when electricity first came out people
were saying wow this is so exciting and you had
products that didn't make sense like you had
electric shoes and electric hats and people
like oh i'm making an electric hat company
don't don't you don't get it you don't you
don't understand electricity is going to the
moon electricity is going to be important
and it's like well yeah but it doesn't mean that
the hat makes sense and that's kind of the way d5
is and decentral more broadly distributed ledgers
the idea that you can have a ledger that is run
by peers rather than a trusted person or party uh
is a big deal and but but you want to think about
where that makes sense securities is one area
that it does make sense so i'm very excited about
securities and defy i've been disappointed that
a lot of the kind of main groups and people that
you think of as the d5 leaders haven't been
looking at securities and i think that's due
to misconceptions you know they think like oh
we don't need to do regulated stuff we'll do
this other thing and it doesn't quite work like
that with securities because securities are driven
in the united states by a definition so it's
like the the definition's super broad so all
the good stuff like equity and sharing profits
and having real governance that actually matters
all of these kind of things it's going
to qualify it as a security and you can't
really change that definition unless
you change these 85 year old rules so
your option now is either comply or try
to make something that is outside the
definition uh which usually is not going to
end up being something good the definition
long long long ago already sort of captured
everything that is good so i'd like to see more
defy and securities converge i think that that'll
be powerful and i'm sure that it will come around
oh i can't hear you i think
you've just muted yourself
while you i'm you um so with all of that with
all of that in mind then i kind of want to
get your thoughts on xrp yeah we can hear you
now i wouldn't i want to get your thoughts on
xrp then because the case is still going on um
there's been a few wins um so i just wanted one
to understand where you stand on that and you
know whether you think it's a security or not
um i know you obviously were very um pro
the d-listing because if it is a security
then it should be de-listed um and also if it is
regarded as a security would that be good for it
oh we can't hear you we still
can't hear you let's see if we can
no we still can't hear you
having some tech issues guys
okay well guys we have a lot to talk about so
just hang on while bruce tries to get the get
the mic going we still we still plan you but while
he does that i'm gonna let you know what's coming
because um like i said i have been trying to speak
to bruce for a while and i think we share some
similar opinions when we talk about what's going
on in the world in general when it comes to covid
when it comes to vaccines um so i definitely want
to delve into that we still can't hear you bruce
sorry oh there we go we can hear you yeah we
can hear you yeah yeah yeah about that i'm just
giving away i've just given away what i want
to what i want to delve into in a bit but but
we'll we'll get that but first i want to hear your
thoughts on xrp because that case is still going
um and you know you're obviously very interested
in security so if it is regarded as a security
how will this play out yeah i mean we'll see
what the nobody can predict what the what the
outcome will be the case isn't really so much
about whether it's a security or not and i don't
think that it will rule on that i think
it's because judges typically from what
i understand don't like to go beyond uh what
they're tasked with it's hard enough judge
job to be a judge and if they if the law isn't
saying this is a question where the judge is
tasked with deciding whether this is a security or
not i don't know if they're going to opine on that
uh because that's just extra work and risk for a
judge they risk getting overturned you know ripple
is obviously going to fight that if they i mean
if they said it is a security or not so the the
the suit kind of assumes it's a security and
the sec does generally have uh authority to
say what a security is so xrp's argument is
and ripple's argument is well you're wrong
it's not a security and here's why so it's crucial
to their defense and so it's certainly possible
that that that you know in a perfect world for
them the judge would say yeah you're absolutely
right you're not a security and he would actually
he or she would actually rule on rule on that
and uh and then it would be a win a win for them
of the case and it would clarify this this uh
status that it's not security i don't think
that will happen even if the case goes their way
i i think it would be um overly optimistic for
them you know i don't know if their lawyers
are like hoping that but i uh you know they're
super super sophisticated and smart on this so
uh you know i'm sure they're realistic about
it their main goal i think is just to not lose
you know because it's sort of stacked against
you when you have a case of this nature even
though you have very good lawyers or whatever
um it's kind of stacked against them from from
day one as far as whether it's a security or
not it's certainly um they certainly make a
case for it in that in in the in the complaint
you know and and the sec saying something is
security is pretty harsh it's like if the dea says
something's a drug you know i've used an analogy
before if the dea goes into walgreens and says
hey this cbd lemonade is not really cbd it's thc
two two things one it's really hard for
that lemonade company to go and fight the
cdc or i'm sorry the the dea and and two
walgreens would be insane you you know you
mentioned de-listing walgreens would be insane to
still keep doing that so i i couldn't believe that
people were having discussions you know exchanges
most exchanges delisted but i couldn't believe
there was any discussion once you have a federal
regulatory authority say something is uh is a
security therefore it's illegal for you to deal
in if you're not a registered securities broker
i think they'd be crazy not to because you're
basically banking your whole future on not
only hoping that that that ripple will win but
hoping they win in such a way that clarifies it
and even then it might be kind of like uh
you know you're still in trouble sort of like
when a cop tells you to stop running away even if
you're the wrong even if it's a mistaken identity
you can still get in trouble for not obeying that
so once they said it was once the sec says this
is a security i think it was december 22nd or
something like that i was just like wow i mean
game over for at least for exchanges for now um
so uh so yeah i think it was smart to de-list it
yeah i saw i think it was famous that have uh
relisted it um at the moment i think somebody else
says as well i can't really remember but i think
at the time it was very interesting because people
were very um i think there was this idea that you
know when they first they come for you and then
they'll come for the next one and the next one and
so people are sort of saying this is an example
of hostility towards cryptocurrencies it's
not about xrp so do you think that we're gonna
okay we're talking about the states
but let's let's yeah we can talk about
do you think that we're gonna see um hostility
towards it the kind of possibility that we've
seen in nigeria for example india turkey um or do
you think this was a genuine issue with xrp as an
isolated case yeah i think well it's not so much
isolated because there's a lot of other companies
and groups in the same situation as hot water but
i don't see us going into a situation like like
india or nigeria a lot of those countries have
been very ham handed and and not nuanced it's
just sort of like oh we're going to ban all crypto
and then people will complain and say okay we're
not going to ban anything um the united states
has been driven more by which regulate we have
very old law and a lot of work that's been done
in this so it's driven mainly by which regulat
which regulatory authority is looking at something
in this case it's the sec so the sec really cares
just about one thing is is it a security if it is
was it offered properly and is it being exchanged
properly according to their rules if it's cftc
they care about other things you know so the
and then there's money transmission and ofac and
other regulations that uh different authorities
care about um and and it kind of which bucket
you're in you know we care very much about
securities obviously being a securities broker
but uh most exchanges care about money transmitter
license so it depends which which regulatory
authority is after it but i don't see this
uh as a broad top-down uh government being
anti-bitcoin kind of thing even if if xrp loses
this it doesn't necessarily have wide uh reaching
impact to other cryptos because it's certainly not
bitcoin the sec has specifically said bitcoin is
not a security and they also said that ethereum
may have been a security at its offering and you
probably shouldn't do that type of offering again
but it's not now so they've they've definitely
acknowledged that uh some things are not
securities when they're digital assets so they
don't have the authority over that so it's not
the same as some kind of king or prime minister
or something who has like all power authority just
saying you know this is banned like we've seen in
some of the even more authoritarian countries yeah
for me personally i feel like we've reached
that we've kind of gone over that hurdle
of could this be banned could could something
stop it i mean especially what's happening in
miami um with the mayor i'm so impressed i'm so in
awe i wish we had that in london um i'm absolutely
annoyed you know and i think there are even some
states in in the us which are accepting bitcoin um
for taxes i think it was ohio but then they they
went back on that but whatever it's it's movement
and it's positive and it's positive and um so
i think we've kind of passed that hurdle but
you know we were talking earlier and
you sort of mentioned bitcoin as that
sound money and that store of value and
everything else could potentially be building
um and one of these companies which is building
is vechain and v chain have um i think i i've
read yesterday have recently gone live um with
cyprus to create the first i think it's a covert
19 vaccination passport basically using blockchain
technology um so you've been really vocal about
everything that we've seen so far across the
last year um firstly i want to get your thoughts
on covert passports because this is really hot
right now and i'm actually based in israel where
well i'm based in israel for the minute where
they have coveted 19 passports i've been turned
down in certain places i couldn't get in because
i'm not vaccinated um you're shaking your head so
tell me your thoughts on this yeah i think it's
just crazy we've seen this absolutely insane
march of authoritarianism over the last year
it's just really a human tragedy and uh you
know we've seen this many times in history and
now here we are uh being able to witness it
uh firsthand where you just have complete and
total uh lack of logic and and in the name of
science of all things it's completely
not science it's totally politics
and you have it wrapped in with all kinds of other
things with you know social bad social ideas and
socialism and uh you know race and climate
and everything else being bundled into this
this one you know basically cult which is uh
you know an authoritarian state worshipping cult
and it has its own rituals and and badges
and magic words just like any other cult
or you know twisted religion in history uh and
it's very murderous and very deadly to people
and um it's it's completely political and you
have signals like a mask or a vaccine passport
or these things which are which are really
designed for signaling much more than any real
uh you know the people who wear a mask generally
like outside jogging are doing it either because
they're really stupid and they just don't have
critical thinking skills they don't understand
anything especially actual science
or more likely they're doing it for
signaling which is a kind of a strange and weird
uh situation that we're in where we have people so
willing to give their soul to this religion called
the state that they're willing to just um abuse
their kids even or let all logic go out the window
i mean you literally have people saying like
oh i'm so like they're bragging about getting a
vaccine which is weird enough but then they're
bragging about their kids getting it and they
have kids in in masks with plexiglass around them
and there's people who are on that side they're on
the side who thinks that kindergartners who have
i calculated it the other day i think it was seven
zeros or four or five zeroes with a seven after it
is what the odds are of a child even even going to
the hospital over it so it's this extraordinarily
it's way less than a one in a hundred kind of
chance um and it gets less and less as more
people are vaccinated and uh you know we have more
hurt immunity more people with antibodies you have
people with something with a far less than one
percent chance and they're using it and they're
and they're putting kids behind plexiglas and st
taking little children who are kindergartners and
making them wear a mask all day long on the
playground just totally not logical it's not
logical it's not protecting them in any way at all
it's a it's a total sick uh social signaling thing
and and so you do have a lot of very strange
things going on in the world right now with this
you know with this whole march of
authoritarianism i think it's quite
scary and dangerous bitcoin is one of
the things that motivates me i feel like
we have so little power against this you know
horrible march of evil but we do have power
over bitcoin you know it's the one thing that
the authoritarians haven't figured out how to
kill or crush or co-opt yet so we can just sort
of you get frustrated you can just go throw throw
dollars at the wall and turn them into sets and
at least you're opting out in some small way
there's a lot there um i obviously i think you
know i agree with you on everything that you said
and i think that um something that i saw the other
day um which blew my mind and for me this was like
the epitome of it was um parents offering their
children up um for the vaccine for trials and i i
use the word trial because it was a trial the
news reporter said it was a trial and these are
three-year-olds getting experimental vaccines and
parents were very excited and they were signaling
virtue signaling and they were sort of saying um
you know we we we wanted to make sure our daughter
had um had a say in this oh i'm sorry she's three
what can i say what kind of state does she have if
you asked her should we be homeless for a week
she'd go yeah that would be really fun let's do
that of course don't do that um so my question to
you is is why is it why why is this happening and
also why is everything being lumped into one
because if you right now you can tell how somebody
believes about something by asking them one thing
right like if you if you wear a mask on your own
chances are you're probably one of those climate
freaks as well right so how how why is this a
thing like why are things lumping together
what why is does that make sense sure yeah
it's the nature of power and authoritarians you
know we have in the world makers and takers you
have people who build stuff who do cool things
who invent things they and they make restaurants
and and construction sites and they invent new
computers and software and they create podcasts
and they create movies and they do stuff and then
you have people who take it you have people who
just take it because they don't have those skills
so they build up skills that enable them to take
stuff and those skills start out at the community
activist level and they're the the brand of uh
you know clown in your local town who's uh going
to all the town board meetings and making little
nitpicky uh rules to bug people and then they rise
up and become the next level legislator i don't
know how it works in in uk but you know in the
us would be like a state senator or a state rep
and then they go up to congress and then they
become under secretary or whatever it's just and
and all of that is about accumulating more power
so you have more power over people and you have
one group of people who think they know better and
they should have the power and they should have
the resources and they know they should have the
money and that you know nobody should have nine
billion dollars or whatever that they should have
it bernie sanders should have it aoc should have
it because they have this belief that they've
been fooled into thinking that these people
know how to allocate resources better so you have
these things where they say you know oh if we you
know we should nobody should be a billionaire we
should tax all the billionaires it's all kind of
in line it's all about taking it's all about
taking um saying oh you know that it's it's
based on greed and jealousy and people who could
never produce anything bernie sanders nancy pelosi
elizabeth warren these people couldn't survive
in in one of our startups for five seconds they
couldn't even probably appear on your podcast
and even speak coherently other than typical
uh you know nonsensical political talking points
that they do on every other podcast that they do
they can't have a real conversation you couldn't
have somebody like elizabeth warren go in and hold
their own in a bitcoin uh clubhouse room or at a
bitcoin meetup or or something like that they just
don't have that skill set they have no idea what
they're talking about they don't know how to build
they don't know how to add any value to society
so all they can do is steal from the people who
do create they can look at it and say oh well
zuckerberg has more than me let's figure out
how to you know gain power over zuckerberg which
ultimately translates into having uh more money so
they so they built up a religion around this and
the religion is one that uh you know has its own
like i say it's it's it's its own uh magic words
and everything and and it that's why it ends up
being encompassed because you you have this this
cohesion that that the members of a group get you
know there's there's human needs that people have
one of them is being part of a group significance
is another one um variety is another one you know
carl young's uh human needs um you know these are
things that this is why people join gangs it's
why people join cults and this is a cult so people
join it and it's and and the more magic words that
you have around it you know you put your pronouns
in your bio and you say blm and you wear a mask
and you do all of these other things the more that
people think that that's you know part of their
identity and the more they believe the nonsense
so people will put people will actually put blm
in their bio thinking they're doing something good
like oh i care as if as if those who don't put it
don't care or as if you don't put your pronoun in
your bio that you're not supporting trans people
or something it's just a preposterous sort of
notion um but but that's how you gain power over
somebody by like a frog in the boiling water you
just get them a little bit at a time a little bit
of the time like oh no no let layla just just just
put your pronouns in your layla just just do that
uh oh no we just need you to say this and what
it is is is if you let the woke magic you know if
you're dealing with the cults okay and you and you
ignore them they don't have power over you so
so you know there's a there's an account that
i read one time about the uh one of these um
voodoo uh like a witch doctor type of person
who put a curse on somebody and the curse
the person who had the curse was like ah
like they immediately changed their whole
physiology their state and they really did become
sick so there's curses where you could put a curse
on somebody and people actually die because they
believe it so much and if if a foreigner goes to
one of those cultures and they say i put a curse
on you layla you're like uh okay and you walk out
you go to starbucks it doesn't it doesn't hurt you
brian armstrong just tweeted about he's he said
he was commending another company because they
took the tact he looked he took and and they're
they're saying no politics being discussed and he
said it was courageous the thing is it's it's it's
only courageous if you do he did make a mistake
uh in that he engaged and he let the woke
magic into his house in the first place
as soon as he hired a diversity officer and he
what happened is he tweeted he tweeted black
lives matter because his employees told them to
and then they you're the frog in the boiling water
they come back oh no no no brian you we want
you to tweet it again so he tweets it again oh
no no brian you got to do this now you got to get
another diversity you got to get another one now
you got to do the climate change and if he didn't
stop put a stop to it right now his entire company
would be run by these people maybe they'd even
throw him out you know they're never gonna stop
they're not gonna say oh finally thank goodness
brian finally he gave that one medium post and
now we know that he's on our side he has pledged
to the church of woke and he is he is one of us
and we're going to let the high priest have
approved him they're never going to approve them
there's never enough that you can give so the only
proper response when you deal with woke lunatics
is to ignore them and not be part of their
religion and not let it have any effect on
you don't see these people coming to people up
here in new hampshire or people in texas and
saying you know you better put your pronouns
in your bio because people just laugh at them
and they also there's some confidence also where
people you know i know that i'm a good person i
know that i that my beliefs on race are actually
way way way more productive towards the goals that
you that we we actually want with race than the
the actual you know racists who are pushing this
blm type of stuff uh and the other non you
know woke nonsense that they do so i i think
that's the reason you know you you gain power
from this cohesiveness and that's how religion
works you know the more doctrine you have
the more things whether it's how many times
a day you have to pray or you gotta shut your
lights off at a certain time all different kind
of religions have these different rituals and
the church of woke is is no different for sure
yeah i think you know you make a really good
point when you say that these these people who are
supposedly actually racist or whatever it is you
know anti-fascists and all this fun that stuff
um they're actually very counterproductive
and they're almost worse you know
um you know i think as a as a woman i can
speak from like the gender equality standpoint
and i often say that kamila harris only got
that role um because she's a woman and because
she's a little bit darker than you and i that's
the only reason i think she got the role and i
think everybody knows that and in some ways that
is so offensive like i would be so offended i
can't stress this enough i'd be so offended if
somebody hired me because i'm a woman it's so
and do you know what i'm so i'm really true to
this i had a phone call the other day and um
somebody wanted me to get involved in some kind
of marketing and all this stuff and i've had a
conversation and they're like you know when we
need more women in crypto and i was trying to i
was trying to think to myself okay well do i tell
you how i feel about this or should we just keep
the conversation going and in the end i yeah you
know in the end because this is a potential client
um and in the end i was like listen i've got to be
honest that women in crypto thing it's not a thing
for me it's not this isn't going to connect us if
you're like pushing this it's not a thing for me
um because you know if you're saying that
you want me to be part of like your project
and all this stuff because i'm a woman then
i find that offensive i would much rather
you i'd much rather you want me to be a part of
your project because of the value that i offer
um whatever that value is it depends on who the
audience is it doesn't matter um but if i'm honest
i'm a little bit frightened like i'm scared um
because we're going down this path and i think
before covid we were on a path whereby it's like
oh well forget the pronouns i'm not going to use
that you know if you're off twitter it's really
not happening in the real world um but but covet
is is happening and it's kind of and it's like a
real world manifestation of all this woke madness
um and i don't really know what we're gonna do
i don't know whether i'm really gonna need to
take the vaccine if i want to travel and live a
normal life um i think now it's having real world
implications outside of this pronoun and blm
stuff and so this is concerning for me yeah
i mean the the the the path to violence begins
with this religious idea that we're right and
that's that's how wars over religion have been
fought for you know one one one group prays four
times a day the other praised five times a day
or you know it's it's this belief or that belief
that people um you know that people fight over
and they have for you know they have for years
and so um you know i think it's very
dangerous you know it's not just a
you know woke slogans that you can ignore it has
real world effect you know these these people are
i mean there's people being arrested right now um
and you know you see these horrible videos it used
to be shocking but now there's so many of them we
don't even bother being shocked but you'll see a
a mother being tased in front of her kids you know
because she's at a school board this just happened
the other day she went to a school board meeting
to complain about the math she didn't wear a mask
so they tased her it's like what kind of society
are we in you know they tasing people and stomping
on their head with boots is a bad idea and uh and
and that's you know that's the side that we're on
you know when you when you say we're right and
we have the law behind us that that's just a 100
guaranteed recipe for for violence uh and and we
see that and and it's and and interestingly the um
the problem isn't seen by the people who are
pushing it because uh they're the they're the
cause of the problem i mean they're the
reason that there's so much violence so
they're looking for any other solution other
than that um to you know to blame you know they
usually racism or something like that when it's
really just you know kind of bad policies and
an overall status uh you know pro
status kind of um you know outlook
so i have a i have a question um greta thumbbag
um what she's been you know greta yeah greta yeah
yeah greta okay so okay so look there there's
this push for a certain kind of um there's a
this is huge environmental push right now um
albeit greta's been silent since covered she's
sort of coming back on the move um i'm sure she's
an innocent very nice individual um but behind her
there's a machine and there's of course there's
100 a machine i can see because i can tell by the
marketing i can tell by the fact that she's almost
an 18 year old girl who they continuously present
as a 10 year old um you know so it's kind of like
children and and all this stuff but do you think
that there's actually a um sinister um a sinister
agenda behind all of this and before you answer i
think in some cases there is so if i look at like
let's just take the democratic party as an example
so i genuinely think that they want to keep the
minorities down like i genuinely think that they
want to keep black people down like i genuinely
think that joe biden try joe biden says you know
you're not black if you don't vote for us i mean
how revolting is that and he's done nothing i was
reading tweets today he's done more for like the
asian community and so on than he's done for any
black people in america um all of their promises
have fallen through you know you have you have um
even even in the uk to be honest but it's
more of a thing in america you have um you
have policies which reward bad behavior there's no
ins that you know there's nothing is incentivizing
any good behavior keeping families together
they're incentivizing broken families um you
know incentivizing riots and and so on it's so
stupid so i do think that's sinister but overall
do you think there's actually a genuine sinister
kind of push here yeah i do um a lot of times the
people who are involved are unwitting and evil
come kind of uh evolves organically it's like
uh it's like a virus you know you i was a medic
when i was in the navy they call it a corpsman
um and uh so i worked in hospitals and stuff like
that and um the program was i was in there was a
lot we were in the water a lot and you know uh and
and and so the littlest tiny injury on your foot
can turn into a really bad nasty injury if you're
in the salt water and you don't clean it properly
you know just a little little sliver a little cut
it can get quite nasty and if you just never take
care of it keep getting worse i mean you could end
up in the hospital over i mean you could probably
die really you know a bad enough infection could
kill you and that's the way that a lot of this is
a lot of people aren't really it's not so much
that they have a master plan for for evil but
they have a plan for furthering their own power
and that power corrupts and they have a plan for
uh you know just this kind of collectivist
sort of you you you are right about i think um
it's it's a very interesting thing with uh with
with race in america where we have the group who
talks about race the most i i agree with you
is by far the most racist and i think their
policies have been terrible and i think that's
ironically why so check this i just pulled this up
this is this is interesting so so philando castile
democrat mayor democrat um governor democrat state
george floyd democrat uh mayor democrat governor
alton sterling democrat mayor democratic governor
freddie gray democrat mayor democrat governor
eric garner democrat mayor democrat governor
dwayne wright michael brown brianna taylor every
single one of them it's overwhelmingly democrat
it's a democrat appointed police chief
democrat police unions who appoint the who
who endorse the democrats democrat legislatures
blue states in many cases a democrat governor
in every single case democrat mayor in every case
so my question is like is it a problem of racism
that caused these people to die or is it something
else if it is racism then we should say well
why is there so much racism in all of the all of
the democrat communities um if it's not racism we
should ask you know what it is i think the true
answer uh is more nuanced you know it's easy
to say it's trump's fault you know oh they all
died because orange man racist like really well
if it's if you have a democrat mayor democrat
governor democrat appointed police chief and
a police union that that endorsed the democrats
and all the laws are written by democrats and
they're enforcing the democrats and most of the
police actually are democrats too is it really
racism they just came out the attorney general
who's black uh said that that um in the uh
the uh the george floyd case
there's no evidence that chauvin
was was racist and of course there isn't because
if we wouldn't if there was we would have known it
if ever in his entire life uh derek chovan
made one racist comment or one racist joke
or did anything at all racist if he if he was
slightly racist to an ex-girlfriend in high
school we would have heard about it i believe you
would have heard about it so the fact is there
wasn't any racism at all regarding this and most
of these other cases there wasn't racism at all
the problem isn't racism the problem is statism
statism is the problem you have a bunch of
bone-headed uh authoritarians eric garner
died because they're of a loose cigarette law
so you have these people who say oh there ought
to be a law and that's the typical democrat kind
of thing you know bernie sanders wants to regulate
deodorant or whatever and fuzzy actually i didn't
know that yeah he mentioned that same same
week he said he wanted to regulate uber but uh
um you you end up with this this situation where
um you you you know the the the pro the real
problem is statism you know uh massachusetts where
we used to live boston has four times the cops
that uh uh san jose has you know it's just
it's and they they have just they have even
more crime and a lot of these places they have
more cops bigger budgets why do they have so
much crime um and and it's easy to just blame
it on racism but it's especially confounding
if you blame it on like the other party who's
not even there like well why how does how does
trump affect louisville he's not there you know
the the fault of the louisville violence should
if anybody should go to those elected officials
who are overwhelmingly democrat and uh and if
it is racism i think there is some racism um but
it's actually on the left side uh but more but to
be fair i could do a sound bite just like the left
does and i could say ah they're the the left's all
racist and they're they're the real racists and
that that's not quite accurate either i don't
think a lot of them intend to be racist i think
they they're putting racist policies out there and
they're unintentionally racist which is ironic uh
but the bigger problem than race is just statism
if you have a whole bunch of stupid laws and a
whole bunch of cops you're gonna have violence
and you're gonna have issues and you're gonna have
people killed of all of all colors well um what
you said actually reminds me um of the whole
gender pay gap issue um and i think it's also
far more nuanced um you know you can look at the
facts and you can say okay well you know women are
statistically paid less than men doing
the same job or whatever it is you could
look at the facts and say more black people are
killed by accident white people whatever it is
but it's far more nuanced um just to go on a side
note i'm one of those people that i don't believe
in the gender pay gap at all i'm i'm a huge jordan
peterson fan um and he breaks it down beautifully
um yeah like he he's fantastic about it um but
but i think that you know with with the with
these policies i i do just i i do so you see with
america america is far more um the race relations
there are far more intense than around the rest
of the world okay so bear with me for a sec
in the uk we don't we don't have this
kind of animosity that you guys have
um even in canada they don't have it and i'm
saying to a lot of canadians about this and during
that time of george floyd and then all the blm
protests in the uk we actually started to um have
very similar protests and it was actually a really
sad sight to see um because we're our communities
are so integrated um it's just not a thing for us
um of course racism is always a thing but but like
it to the to the extent that you have these racial
tensions in the us we don't really have that um in
in the uk and i do a lot of bitcoin work on tick
tock and uh tick tock is very heavy gen z and it's
constantly race after race after race the issues
scrolling through there are so many issues and and
you know it's just like why do white people always
say this and then a then a white person comes in
and says why do black people always say and then
and then a canadian comes in and a canadian's
like what's wrong with you americans it's just
you guys doing this and i can understand why
but but my concern is americanization is real
americanization is a real thing and so i worry
that it that this kind of racial tensions will
spread globally yeah we'll export it well the
thing is we didn't used to be like this either
this is a new thing yes we've had races racism
and racial issues going back hundreds of years and
we we have uh you know very bad race ra you know
slavery and other things in our history but this
new thing this this whole uh thing where everybody
is is um segregated by race that's new that's like
the last five years has been on a huge huge update
because i remember i was talking to somebody and
they happened to be like a gen z it was it was a
college student and he said to me i said something
and he says well that's easy for you to say you're
a white male and i was like totally shocked
the first time i heard that i was like what
what are you talking about what are you you're
judging me by the skin i couldn't believe it
now you hear that every five minutes i i actually
stopped identifying myself as male or white just
to get people to leave me alone so so and it works
great by the way with the wokes the wokes are all
every single conversation they want to put me in
a box and i just simply say please don't assume
my race and please don't assume my gender and then
they get really angry especially about the gender
well you're obviously a man i say as i said
please don't assume my gender i'd rather not
i'd like to be judged by my words not by being
put in the little box that you can so you can say
oh he's the wrong skin color he's his opinion
is less valuable no thank you i'd rather have my
opinions be judged not by what somebody else's
perception is about what my gender is um and
this so this whole thing was kind of invented uh
you know the first blm protests were kind of fell
flat they were run by idiots um it you know and
then but that movement kept trying to come back
and it was mainly that the anti-trump media who
really ran with this racist racist racist racist
thing which i don't really buy necessarily
trump certainly had a lot of problems and
he made some stupid comments if you talk about
stupid comments being evidence of racism there's
no comparison at all between him and biden biden
says things has said absolutely ridiculous things
much much much worse than trump and he's actually
had much worse policies too so and a lot of the
things that trump supposedly said he didn't
he didn't even say one of the biggest ones
that has been um you know repeated continually
by the media is this lie that he said that uh
you know neo-nazis are fine people and he
specifically said the opposite of that he said
i am not talking about the neo-nazis or white
nationalists so if you say that in a sentence
and in the same sentence you clarify
i'm not talking about the neo-nazis
and white nationalists then you can't use that
as a quote that didn't stop the new york times
and every other lying media from saying that and
it was even repeated by biden in the in the debate
so you have this huge thing in the national con
consciousness of tens of millions of people which
is a lie and there's hundreds and hundreds of
examples like that that uh that that pushed this
this race narrative so that contributed to it
and then this idea this leftist collectivist
you know socialist communist idea that
people should be put into boxes like oh the
uh you know white people over here and black
people over here and you have this experience
and privilege and all of this other stuff and
then you end up inevitably with people saying
you know oh white people say this black people
say that and i i found that very disturbing
that wasn't a thing and and it's
really sad with gen z because the media
and the leftists has put pushed this idea into the
the gen z's head that you know everybody with a
red hat or or every republican or whatever is some
kind of almost character you know i always want
to ask i'm like where are all these racists you
talk about it all the time where are these actual
i mean where are the real racists i don't see very
many of them at all like when we talk about like
all these races racial issues as far as like real
actual races like actual neo-nazis and actual uh
you know kkk types it's an extraordinarily tiny
tiny tiny number and so it's like what you know
it's almost like they're living in 1950 you
know that they think that people go home and
you know mutter the n word about somebody
because they don't like the skin color
and the same thing you see this with you see
this with with to a lesser degree women and
and um gays and other other things where
you have this kind of gen z attitude like
oh yeah it's going to be real hard for her to get
a job in software because she's a woman it's like
where is that a thing actually show me a ceo
who's a tech ceo who's legit sitting there
saying oh i got to fill this engineering job
we really need another c plus plus decoder but
the only ones who applied one of them is kind
of brown and the other one's a woman i mean
that's just not a thing that person would be
such an outlier they'd be such a weirdo they
wouldn't even be a normal i mean do they exist
yeah sure you can dig it up i mean the media will
find these people even even for the media it's
hard you gotta really dig to find somebody who
actually will look you in the eye and say no women
don't know math as well as men i mean that's just
it's a character you don't need to spend any more
effort on that character than you do on somebody
who thinks any other ridiculous thing they're
not a mainstream part of society but the media
has tried to push it and make it
seem like you know half the country
is racist sexist uh homophobic anti-asian now is
is another new thing uh and and you and they you
know they have this this this horrible murder and
they immediately try and make it into a race issue
i think it's just a murder issue the guy who who
killed the original group of people who who mostly
were asian it seemed that he was just a crazy
horrible evil person who but and even if it was
motivated by race it's like oh okay but does that
mean it's it's a trend you know it's it's just
it's very easy for the media to manipulate these
things in a way that increases division and people
start thinking each other it's it's very sad i
think people think more in terms of color in the
last five years than ever before you see somebody
and then and then they start to think because
they've been told and because the left has pushed
and pushed and pushed say black people are this
way and then this white people are this way then
when you when you do hire that engineer you have
some people who think oh we hired a black engineer
and that's a tragic tragic thing that is just
evil and i blame the left for that i don't want
to see somebody as a black engineer i don't even
want to care about it and we shouldn't care and
this division and this idea categorizing people
by race is a bad way to categorize and i use
that line a lot i tweet it every single time
i see something stupid and it's oftentimes big
corporations citizens bank did it the other day
they have a thing black uh banker bank customers
do this who cares i don't care what whether what
color skin somebody has how much balance they
have in there you know but black people like the
drive-in window more like why why do you need to
do it and i respond every time with that and the
reason i use that line is because it's hard to
attack i just simply say categorizing people by
the color of their skin is a bad way to categorize
people and i think that's a jordan peterson line
actually um and it's because i learned if you get
into a dialogue you get into an argument i don't
want to get into an argument i'm just saying a
statement that's hard for them to disagree with um
and uh so anyway i i think that it's tragic
that the media and the left have and the
right to but especially the left in the media
has really pushed this this narrative to put
people in in boxes and divide people and i feel
horrible and and the biggest victim of it is
uh the people that are supposedly trying
to that they're trying to benefit from this
the biggest uh drawback i i see people now where i
get resumes where the first thing they mention on
their resume is that their race i get resumes and
they'll say i'm uh filling the you know i'm i'm
this race and i i'm an engineer you know kind of
like you you women you know i'm a woman in bitcoin
if your first thing that you're putting on your
resume is your race and then the second and third
thing is some race related club that you're in a
race related thing i feel bad for you and you've
been sold a bill of goods by the left who isn't
there to help you they're there to get your votes
and they view it as as the black vote for example
um which they think is their birthright just like
when the when the democrats were um you know in
in in league with the plantations and the and the
kkk you know they were some of the biggest races
historically in history and there were there was
no like party switch but um yeah i think it's just
absolutely tragic what the media has been doing
yeah i i obviously totally agree with it all
um and i think that i used to work um as a
traditional journalist in london um and my time
there was fascinating and i knew i didn't belong
um i knew it i i didn't know what the problem
was until i left but but i felt like something
wasn't right what wasn't right was the way that
i saw the world um and you know i think i made
a comment about the metoo campaign i was working
on a sunday um so it was really chilled you know
we're all just only a few of us in the office in
the newsroom and um i made a comment about the
metoo campaign and i was absolutely slaughtered
for it it was so unprofessional i was just people
just came after me in the newsroom and uh the news
editor did nothing and i'm like what is happening
um and you know you can't say anything you
can't you can't commune communicate anything
and um you know i think you're totally right when
you say that if the most interesting especially
on twitter the most interesting thing about you
in your bio is that you're there's the color of
your skin your sexuality and your gender you must
be a pretty boring person um you know like i feel
i have so much to say and if the most interesting
thing about me is talking about being female
like i'm pretty damn boring then because you know
there's not really much it's already much exciting
to say about that so it's a real it's a real tell
if somebody puts that at the top of their resume
you know it's a real tell um so okay we've been
on for nearly an hour so i i don't want to keep
you too long um but how do like moving forward
with all of this i spoke about this with michael
arrington and he says that we're going down a dark
path and eventually there'll be a flipping and it
will change a good friend of mine said that
he sees the next 30 years as a dark as a dark
time what are your thoughts do you think that you
know where there'll be a correction at some point
i hope so um i do see us going into very dark
territory and we we've done this many times in
history where you do have these long periods of
darkness because once you have authority like
they have with the with all the lockdowns and the
masks and stuff like that it's much harder for the
people to get that back it's much easier for them
to uh just increase once you have this big huge um
authoritarian apparatus of tyranny and it's
and once you have that in the power of the
authoritarians which we have now it's ten times
harder to get it back and so it's much easier for
them to just add some new thing like to say you
know okay now it's now it's the next vaccine you
know i mean they're already talking about these
yeah every six months yeah yeah oh we we just know
that this one in a hundred year uh virus is it's
here forever now so you're going to need another
vaccine passport in six months and then and then
you're going to have you know biosurveillance and
then it's like well shouldn't we also use that to
stop the child molesters too and save the children
and if we're gonna stop the child molesters
shouldn't we also stop the human traffickers
and also what about the drug dealers yeah you
know maybe we should just stop the drug users too
you know and before you know it you get this
thing where it's like oh okay you're a drug user
or you're you you didn't i mean there there's
people who were who were saying that you know i
mean basically treat people who wear red hat as a
terrorist you know the this whole uh you know it's
a it's a it's a very bad combination when you have
huge authoritarianism with uh zealots and lunatics
and so so i do worry about it i'm optimistic
about technology i'm optimistic about human nature
i'm optimistic about uh people's ability to
to um you know fight back uh and and new ways
to fight back like technology you can opt out
through bitcoin or something like that but it
is scary overall i mean i try and be optimist i
i really hope that uh there's a backlash the good
news is there's a lot of people i mean you look at
florida people just opt out they're just like man
not being a member of the church church awoke
uh thank you and and there's got to be something
internal where people say wait a minute i'm
on the side that's tasering moms and locking
kindergartners in a plexiglas shield with a mask
on their face all day long while they're on the
playground for for something that has a one in
ten thousand chance of killing them what have we
done here what are we thinking you know uh sorry
there's a spider on my mic i just jumped sorry
i don't know i i was distracted earlier because
my dog was chewing my core he moved okay i'm
yeah but that i mean that's what i think i i feel
like it is a very dark time but i'm i'm cautiously
optimistic we do have some checks and balances
in place and other things i i would like to see
you know it's very hard to fight this kind of
stuff because the best people to fight it are
the ones who don't want to the people who are
trying to build you know who just want to mind
their own business naval has mentioned before that
he doesn't want anything to do with politics it's
divisive zero-sum game but the problem is if we
all sit by the lunatics are going to take over
the asylum these people are absolutely evil and it
and we can't just say oh it's republicans versus
democrats or it's this versus that it's evil
versus good and we can't sit on the sidelines as
much as i would like to i would like to just never
even mention it i wouldn't even like to talk about
it there's not a lot of gain even just coming on
and talking about it there's not there's more harm
than gain and you can end up in the in the sights
of the woke or the antiphon and they could try and
make things miserable for you for a little while
but um you sort of have to because if you don't
those people who spend a life figuring out how to
get power over others are in a very good position
now to just continue to increase that power and
and and uh i tweeted the other day my friend told
me a story about his family from iraq and they had
worked really hard to they made money ages ago and
then they the the patriarchs of the family were
like hey we have enough money now we can afford
with trusts and stuff to send everybody to school
everybody's going to be an academic so they're all
academics and poets and thinkers and scientists
and just wonderful and i said that sounds awesome
and he said yeah we taught we we they were taught
growing up you don't need to be in the military
service and political service is a little bit
beneath you you can be an academic or philosopher
our family has enough resources that we're going
to put a priority on schooling and i said that
sounds awesome and he said no that's not the
end of the story he said saddam came along and
they couldn't do anything about it he just took
over and those who fought him were killed so you
can't just stay above the fray and you can't just
ignore politics politics won't ignore you politics
these people will kill you over a loose cigarette
just like they killed eric garner and it was the
statists who killed eric garner not racist not
donald trump it's status statism is the most evil
uh religion and uh the the the status out there
will will they won't kill you but they will order
somebody to kill you over anything no uh offense
is too trivial wearing a mask loose cigarettes uh
you know one of the other ones on my list there
was killed um over a warrant the original warrant
was was basically over a joint it was i
think it was a misdemeanor or something so
you know the the state of the aoc bernie sanders
elizabeth warren crowd will murder you dead for
not pledging to the church of woke so you got
to just opt out get away from the church of woke
and uh and and you know focus on peace and
stuff but but we do have to fight it i mean
i think that it's worth fighting some of these
authoritarian things you know i'm i'm personally
becoming more and more against masks we have a the
you know the mandate is ended in our state uh but
i'm more getting along the the the tucker carlson
line which is you know i'm thinking about saying
hey i'm offended if you're wearing a mask your
mask is making me uncomfortable please take it off
uh because we just have to stop the insanity
otherwise they're just you know they're they'll
put shots in the arms of kids and uh having them
wear armbands and every other crazy thing so
but i am optimistic about people ability to do
that people are kind of fed up and and hope and
that and the ideas of the woke crowd are so so
so bad the lockdowners and the wokes they're all
the same as you mentioned you know the climate blm
lockdowners woke uh pronouns they're all the same
arrangements of idiots and and you know as i
mentioned one important point is you know that as
i said woke magic only works on yourself and you
talked about when you're in a newsroom yeah the
the the professions that are i've already pledged
to the church of woke they have it the hardest so
you can't be a journalist an entertainer uh look
at gina carano she gets cancelled from one of the
most popular shows because she didn't want to put
pronouns in her bio you know um but that's just
because same as brian armstrong she was in the
space to begin with you won't see somebody else
you won't see kid rock getting canceled like that
even though he's an entertainer because he never
participated her biggest mistake was to engage
them in the first place you should just discounted
them as lunatics that they are and maybe she'd
still have her job but certain professions media
obviously politics uh academia and the and uh you
know you know you know the the press and a couple
others you just can't say anything academics just
can't say anything i feel really bad for people
in academia but there's a lot of people on the
other side who know that this is crazy and they're
they're fighting against it or they're just opting
out and just not allowing somebody to say because
the lunacy gets crazy and crazier and what happens
is as more people opt out they have less power
i mean you can't go to like a republican um and
i don't mean to always make it about republican
democrat but i'm just saying uh it's harder to
attack your typical like ted cruz with some woke
thing because he's already opted out he's like no
it's not a thing so who do they attack they attack
academics talk to an academic talk to somebody in
the media or talk to an entertainer and all three
of those people i guarantee you will tell you
that they're pressured i know an academic who was
outright pressured uh just to basically pledge to
the church they actually went to this this is an
adult professor the university went to this adult
professor and said you need to read this book
there's a book about critical race theory because
somebody in their class said some preposterous
thing that you know like they didn't whatever
they didn't they didn't say them right magic words
um but as more people opt out eventually you know
they're going to eat their own and you'll have
your own you know you know ellen was was roasted
because she did something earlier you know you
have your own members of the cherokee church of
woke who are getting tried for heresy it's like
oh okay you you did these these these and these
statements but you didn't say this other statement
or you didn't pledge to this group or you didn't
donate enough or you didn't give enough of your
soul so you're going to have even academics but
they're all wimps because they need the jobs
really badly and so you don't see the academics
you know fight it but eventually you will because
the the woke lunacy won't have anybody to feed
on but itself and then they'll starve and then
hopefully die down we hope yeah we do hope and i
think that um you make a really important point
and it's something that i've really actively
tried um to do is as i've grown my own audience
um people know where i stand so nobody can hold
me to any bs standard of any kind right so like
since the beginning of lockdown i've said i'm
not okay with that since the masks i've said
i'm not okay with it for the very reason that
you've said because you know it's a gradual
you know it's it's masks today but what
else is it tomorrow it's forced medical
experiments on children tomorrow right um so yeah
absolutely you know i i don't ever want to be
held to account by my audience for um you know
not being woke enough like if you're woke leave
you know leave i i yeah you got to be uncancelable
you know you have to treat it just like a crazy
religion you know if somebody came in and said
oh you know layla the moon god uh requires you
to turn your light switch on and off four times a
day and you need to you really ought to be posting
that you're doing this and say hey i did the
life switch thing or you know whatever and
you just say uh no and you move on that's the
only response for these folks because they're
violent i mean if you get into it with them they
might kill you you know so you're better off just
just ignore them i mean just last point on that
i um i work with quite a few really amazing
different companies in the space and um somebody
i have a really good relationship with one of
the ceos and um he told me that somebody reached
out to him and was just like how do you have leia
representing your your company um have you seen
her tweets you know i was just like i only work
with good people i only work with non-cancelable
types so good luck you know um so they thought
that was really funny and the ceo himself is super
red-filled so he was like yeah it's chill it's not
it's not a problem um but it's been so good
talking to you bruce um i've been really
excited to talk to you i've seen your tweets and
to be honest i i was surprised um when i when i
saw um certain things that you tweeted and i
was like oh wow we're really on the same page
um i was really surprised it was really refreshing
and so thank you so much yeah it's refreshing
to talk to you too it's great to uh i mean it's
probably important so i'm glad i did this because
we should all be talking about this and hopefully
you know some people maybe on the fence or
or maybe even a little bit on the woke side will
just look at this and wake up because there's a
lot of really really good people i have a lot of i
you know i didn't really come from the left but i
certainly you know i lived in massachusetts i have
a lot of very left uh issues like and i've been
talking about anti-war and police violence and the
drug war for 20 years um and uh so i definitely
have a lot of camaraderie with a lot of people
on the left who've been you know just driven to
this insanity they got to step back and look at
it so i think it's important what you're doing
so keep up the good work keep being uncancelable
uh i think that's one of the most important things
in today's world because then you can actually
speak truth and that probably makes you one of the
top journalists in the world right now you know
how rare it is like when you said journalists like
barely you know a dozen actual journalists it's
certainly not any of the people at any of the
the media um you know propaganda mouthpieces
you know new york times is just a media
mouthpiece for a very narrow specific thing and
they're even in the case of like they're they're
within wokes talking to other wolks they're
they're like they're starting to attack each other
you have a whole bunch of infighting with
the reporters there it's really hilarious
you know it's and it's an ever dwindling
uh sphere of influence and readers because
it it's just a bunch of you know ultra ultra
blues arguing with each other about you know
who who who put the pronouns in their bio first
and uh nobody cares and then and then the rest of
their so-called news which isn't even journalism
by any stretch it's just it's just mouthpiece
talking points for state media so you you're in
a great position to be uh actual truth-teller
who and you can only be a truth teller if
you're uncancelable so that's good good for you
yeah i hope so you know that is that is the
goal um i just kind of want freedom normality um
and yeah we don't have freedom we don't we don't
have anything and um it kind of comes down to
when you don't allow people to take personal
responsibility it's just socialism you don't
allow people to take personal responsibility
they just won't no one will do anything like
i've even seen here in israel they have um a
scheme where what was similar to what we had
in the uk furlough where they paid people to do
nothing um for a year and uh it's an issue here
people are getting paid they're still getting
paid and people aren't really going back to work
um and then it brings all of us down to the
lowest common denominator um and it robs
them of a year of experience they could have
gotten doing something else yeah absolutely um
yeah i just i i just hope things do get better
and we can live a more free life um i'm trying
to come to florida because i just love that it's
open so that's the goal but um thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure and um hopefully
we can catch up and have a more positive
discussion um at some point by all means sounds
good it was great to uh great to talk to you
all right bye guys and thank you so much
for tuning in we will see you all next week